vous allez écouter skype va y sera peur
c'est complètement fou ça a été un
déferlement aujourd'hui c'est parti
c'est le quart d'heure sans fil dans son
fils tout de suite maintenant on passe
un quart d'heure
alors il y a quelques jours encore il y
avait seulement 200 followers sur
twitter il n'avait seulement que 200
followers
aujourd'hui tout le monde ne parle que
de lui c'est un rappeur qui s'appelle
nick conrad est ce que vous connaissez
ni conrad à leur dire ça
il a fait un énorme scandale avec une
chanson qui s'appelle pendez les blancs
du quoi exactement
maxime gagnon est dit pendez les blancs
et en plus de ça c'est un appel à la
violence je trouve ça pervers lamentable
inaudible je trouve que c'est d'une
terrorisme intellectuel et que ça ne
mériterait même pas d'exister alors vous
êtes mis d'accord pour dire que lucho
est ce que vous a choqué ou pas ou est
ce que vous pensez que c'est dans les
maternités pour autant se divertir et
baignoire et après d'écarteler les
parents que c'est immonde heures avant
avril vers des savoirs que le parquet de
paris a ouvert une enquête pour
provocation publique à la commission
d'un crime ou d'un délit donc il peut
être condamné parce qu'il n'a pas le
droit de dire ça j'ai la nausée la
coriace
il ya donc le ministre a tort car a dit
joe condamne sans réserve ces propos
abjects abjecte et ses attaques
ignominieuse mes services oeuvre au
retrait sans délai des contenus diffusés
il appartiendra à l'autorité judiciaire
de donner des suites appropriées à ces
odieux appels à la haine
est ce que christine kelly vous qui
faisait partie du ces c'est qu'ils vont
enlever toutes ces vidéos est ce qu'ils
vont avaient tous ces crissements m oui
alors justement c'est dommage que ça
soit pas à la télé parce qu'à la télé ça
serait strictement interdite c'est sur
le net c'est là où on voit que ya une
grande dit jeudi commençait sa dunette
ça peut faire c'est mais c'est là où il
faut justement un 5 sur internet et
c'est là on n'y arrive pas mais ce que
je me demande c'est par exemple
aujourd'hui cette chanson là elle est
sur les plateformes personne n'arrive à
l'enlever de youtube mais les gens lever
la voix bizarre c'était sûrement sait
comment ça se fait que c'est repris par
tout commence à succès en ligne the 17
septembre non mais c'est une question
que je pose comment ça c'est que c'est
en ligne depuis le 17 septembre et qu'on
a osé médecins en ligne non à la à la
haine raciale pour stratégie commerciale
grèce exactement c'est olivier vous êtes
spécialiste de musique urbaine qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ça est ce que vous
pensez qu'il a fait exprès qu'il est
allé volontairement très loin pour qu'on
parle de lui ou bien est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils pensent vraiment ce qu'il
a écrit et ce qui l'a chanté
la première chose il faut savoir
connaissent et nick hurran alors je l'
ai découvert quand ce matin mon
téléphone à buzz et avec des appels de
ferrand médias d'accord jour est ce que
vous voulez venir parler de nick machin
c'est personne ou quand même bien
préciser que c'est quelqu'un qui
n'existe pas là maintenant tout le monde
en parle mais même mehdi musique vous
connaissez bien qui est spécial rap
quand le conduit au téléphone il m'a dit
je ne sais pas qui c'est personne ne
sait qui c'est vrai donc ces personnes
c'est mauvais le texte est abject la
vidéo je vous en parle même pas moi j'ai
regardé je me suis arrêté au bout de 3
minutes 30 parce que c'est un regard
d'homme c'est pas défendable et en plus
là où leur a peut être une musique c'est
vrai parfois anguleuses avec des propos
borderline là on est au delà du border
là c'est vraiment c c'est impossible à
défendre et alors il a essayé de se
défendre lui s'est expliqué sur rtl tout
à l'heure en disant que son message
n'avait pas été compris on les voit
effectivement on est dans la provocation
c'est vrai mais en même temps c'est une
image forte parce que ce sont des choses
qui voit qu'ils sont réellement arrivé
au peuple noir
je pense qu'à un raciste en pour de vrai
ne peut pas se vanter de prendre le
micro et lire des choses abominables
comme si dans un clip city pour une
raison si dix pour que les gens se
réveillent réellement peux pas regretter
ce que j'ai dis pas ce que je sais
pourquoi je les dis et je continue à
porter ce message qui est plus en
profondeur est un message d'amour elle
était plus qu'un message de m c'est ce
qu'il est temps que les gens comprennent
la location olivier ccrq c'est là on est
dans 1984 de george orwell le mystère de
l'amour qu'est celui de la haine en face
de tous les maux sont inversés ça ne
veut rien dire n'importe qui qui voit
les mêmes les quelques secondes que vous
avez montré du clip on voit bien que
tout amour c'est de la pure haine et
c'est alors que ça soit arrivé
effectivement à des noirs l' esclavage
c'est effectivement quelque chose qu'une
réalité je vois pas en quoi des sur le
répondeur de reproduire le même discours
en montrant ce genre d'image et entend
ce genre de discours
vincent nico vous qui êtes chanteur je
comprends qu'ils aient un poids peut
être historique
et ça je l'entends tout à fait mais on
peut pas on peut pas dire ça c'est pas
possible
le visage sévère défendu c'est bien sûr
le polémiste dieudonné a soutenu sur son
compte facebook
notre jeunesse est bouillonnante et
plein de talent elle est résolu à en
découdre avec les mensonges de
l'histoire
que dieu nous préserve du piège de la
haine raciale qui n'est là que pour
servir les intérêts nationaux
alors que la corde soutient le pendu la
sélection justifier alors il ment jardin
non pas juste j'ai vu le début du clip
je sais pas comment il a fait ça mais le
début du clip c'est juste un blanc donc
qui ont dit tu vas courir plus vite
parce que je vais tirer dessus à deux
secondes et après tu es mort c'était le
jeu favori des nazis pendant la guerre
c'est tout ce que je veux dire c'est ce
qui m'a vraiment choquée je rentre dans
les crèches
je tue des bébés blanc et j'attrape les
bains les parents mais la seconde est
content quand même c'est des fous
avaient alors qu'on avait été posté le
17 septembre
on a mis beaucoup de temps à s'en rendre
compte est là tout le monde parle de lui
est-ce que vous pensez que il y en a qui
se disent il a réussi son coup parce
qu'il était inconnu
mhsa le danger alors moi je n'en peux
plus de ces gens là parce que sur le dos
de la 10 ont fait de la provocation en
fait ils distillent la haine ne devrait
pas les laisser faire ça c'est ça qui
est inadmissible et le rap est une
musique formidable avec des gens comme
ça mon cas c'est dans le grand public
des images dures alors c'est du
marketing c'est que pour faire vendre